Hachi Machi gang that state trashy tour
is a cook and may we're coming down to
Tampa Florida a couple of tickets left
then we're going to Danny Beach Florida
then we're going up to Raleigh North
Carolina to Good Nights come out and see
us it's a good time yeah gang and that
ain't it we're also going to Louisville
Kentucky Cleveland Ohio Columbus Ohio
we're moving some Dickies if don't don't
miss out get them now you snooze you
lose welcome to another exciting edition
of are you garbage the show where you
find out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage that little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they're going to be
classy yeah they're just a mega old
piece of trash I'm your host stage Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here with hoodies in the new
edition baby she wants to remind you if
you're coming by use the side door she
don't want your trip should mud through
the new parlor I'll tell you that right
now my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is an international
businessman and I'll tell you what right
now my best pal in the whole wide world
and I love them give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure your rate of you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are
then obviously I'd be remissed an
[__] a j-o if I didn't sing it if I
didn't mention the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it out it's a goddamn party over
there love that money and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the Magic Band makes us
all look good works the ones Works to
twos the threes and the fours he crosses
the t's and he dots the eyes and now you
can get a little peek at him on a Toby
cam give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody what up dude
whatever you um yo this guy we got in
here is a type of dude you can't
introduce to your dog because your dog
will love him more than you yes he is
part Labrador I believe
he's a goddamn rock star the long hair
ain't lying we couldn't be more excited
to have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guests back with us
again today third or fourth appearance
here on the show first time here in the
new edition we're so happy to have him
of course you know I'm from billions
he's on tour right now do yourself a
favor get some goddamn tickies at
danceoder.com and give it up for Dan
Soder hey there he is I'm fully back and
yeah we've already determined I am
garbage so now we're just picking
through it now it's just time to pick
through that trash welcome to the party
this place is [__] awesome I was like
walking around for the for the viewers
at home this place is on it's so cool
thank you it's so cool to see you guys
have this thanks man yeah and I mean the
idea was like if you know two dirt bags
hit the lottery what how they would
build and how they would do it I would
want to live here if I wanted a Big Buck
Hunter Machine since I've been 19 years
old but there are you guys both booze
gotta be a time one night where you're
just like in the city you don't want to
go home and you're like I go to sleep in
the studio I would be tempted to sleep
in the studio so much uh he's already
asking like we can't allow it just yet
why would they get mad I don't think so
but who'll move in like holding properly
do you guys have a working kitchen too
right yeah uh not like there's no uh
stove or anything right could there be a
hot place
in jail dude why don't you guys just be
cooking if I was in the back on the hot
plate he's doing this stealing it over
sausages slicing garlic with a razor
yeah okay I'm doing steaks like a good
Fellas yeah dude I love you guys
squatting in your podcast Studio that's
right because the second we do it once
it's [__] game over dude we'll all be
in here I'll be divorcing yeah I always
was like one of those kids where I was
like I could I like wanted to live in a
van when I was a kid yeah because I was
like this is cool my like Uncle had a a
Topper to his truck you know it's tight
he had the bed on top and I remember we
were visiting my uncle and I was like
can I sleep in there wait it was a truck
with the cabin on it yeah you put like
the Winnebago s cap on it it goes out
over and that's where the bed is yeah
and I was like I was so hyped on
sleeping up there sure he's like I have
a nice cabin here in Carbondale Colorado
and I was like let me let me see the
keys to that drop
that truck until you catch a glimpse of
your first spider up there in the corner
oh yeah yeah
I almost just went on Smash Patrol
get away from me the trashiest one is
the little uh the one that you tell the
little cabin that yeah yeah that is
pretty shitty yeah I kind of like them I
got my neighbor had one and I wanted one
so yeah that's what you see him and
you're like
because in Colorado there's a lot of
winnebagos I love a Winnebago
not like the cool big ones like the tour
buses that you see sure like the ones
that people in Arizona have like
snowbirds I'm talking about 16 bikes on
the back crazy I don't want to
curriculum you would see the people come
in on the winner when I lived in Tucson
you would see all the snowbirds come
down and they're [__] Giant
winnebagos and you'll be like damn you
got a house on Wheels what's a snowbird
exactly those are the people that are
from like Minnesota or cold places who
leave and come to Arizona and like like
people have never through February yeah
people go to Florida yeah in the winter
snowbirds exactly and they stay in the
Winnebago that whole season well those
people that live in the heat they get
all angry and then they have to come up
with terms for it yeah
goddamn show I don't like the water in
those things no they're never good yeah
drinking that water bad water pressure
they all smell the crucial it really was
a very fleeting moment in my life of
six to eight years old but I wanted to
sleep in a Winnebago and then now I'm
like that's cool like tour buses I would
like to get to that point but I don't
yearn for it sure you sleep good on them
I slept like a bear family I think about
it weekly because I'm going I'm doing
um the first weekend of the fully loaded
tour no oh y'all I'm gonna be on the bus
with big Jay and Norton yeah your
buddies are all around you Bert was
sleeping right next to me you felt like
having your dad snuggled next I don't
even know what that's like to begin with
it was awesome you guys might fill a
hole I've had since I was five oh it
feels real good I'm gonna be like dude
[__] Bert just let me sleep on your
bus just to get some REM sleep no one of
the professional drivers driving you're
in this I wasn't I was a little
concerned when they were like all right
just go to bed with your feet facing the
driver so you don't immediately break
your neck and I was like oh okay I was
about 400 years deep at the time so I
don't want to get Cliff Burton and we
heard everybody yelling but Cliff oh my
god dude if I
I like to take Edibles before I go to
bed I feel like that would [__] no man
it's cozy in there dude
and the hum of the boss puts you right
out you guys are probably too young for
this but for a while they sold these
things you can get like GI Joe the
Transformers The A Team WWF and it was
it was like a tent that it had a fitted
sheet on the bottom that you would put
over your bed and then it had like the
little wires and it was a little tent on
top of your bed oh no oh clean living
dude are you see that's a thing had my
comic books couple of GIS how big are we
talking here it was like it would just
be like this it would look like a tent
on top like shaped like your bed because
what I would do and as most kids would
do is you'd get under your comforter
with a flashlight or something but then
you'd be breathing that hot humid air
after like two two minutes every time in
a movie when someone's reading under a
blanket I'm like [__] it doesn't
work because you gotta crack that thing
you ain't finishing that chapter yeah
and then put it back down I'm going back
in yeah but I would have lost oh they
were [__] awesome I love that dude
for all my guys yeah dude it was great
he saw the end table behind me goes this
is where I used to keep my guy yeah dude
it was exactly that looked like exactly
like the end table we had at the end of
our couch
you just opened the door and just toys
would flood out yeah they'd pick through
them wasn't always great when like you
know you got yelled at enough or
whatever or every once in a while you
cleaned all your guys up like I kept
them all under the bed and it was
usually a mess but then in every sat you
know every some Saturday I would take it
all out and organize everybody I'd line
the cars up that's great like all the
vehicles up we had like a cribs episode
yeah like a tiny cribs episode
you're like hey what's up it's me Cobra
Commander he's got two waters all lined
up you know you know me if I'm trying to
dominate the whale
here's a couple of my my whips this is
where the magic happened
I [__] each other
it was devastating to find out a lot of
a lot of those were fake a lot of The
Cribs houses were fake red man they were
just rented red man came on the bonfire
and he was like that was a hundred
percent yeah that was like [__]
duplex and stuff he said the thing that
I didn't even it was in brexit it was in
Jersey yeah yeah uh but he told he said
something that made me laugh so [__]
hard where he was like they showed up
earlier than they were supposed to so he
just let him in and was like yeah film
your b-roll I'm going back to sleep and
he just went up and slept for like
another two hours then came downstairs
was like all right what do I need to do
Red Man's stick he's the guy yeah dude
he had like cereal on top of the
refrigerator yeah that wasn't real he
had and I've always wanted one a dollar
box you just throw a crumpled up a
couple years in there and then we need
milk you need bread go to the dollar box
I have had a change bag since 2008.
Ziplocs filled with quarters or whatever
but coin Stars uh Jamie up yeah there's
one in the Bronx I had to go to when I
was
I have a giant bag of change that I've
been saving for [__] 16 years and
it's full I I need to go somewhere you
gotta go to a coin star yeah you got to
go to a Suburban uh Coinstars in the
city there's not that many and they Jam
they don't like doing anything over like
100 bucks because there's not enough
cash in the in the I've I used to be a
long-term I loved Coinstar I was the
best yeah but I but I so that old habit
sure remained however I didn't need the
money so I never drained the best so I
just have this like legitimately 10 10
pounds I would think it's a 10 pound bag
a couple G's maybe no I don't know I
don't know 16 years I'll tell you guys
what it is should be 70 grand it's it's
like this wide this deep and it's like
it's like three of the giant Ziplocs
gallon Ziplocs inside of each other I
mean Katie is like all right bud we're
not taking this into the new apartment
where do I take this chain
you can't do it at Banks anymore they
stop doing it yeah well the TD Bank was
was skimming they all got jammed up
listen I'll sit down with a guy who can
give me a free pen and we can negotiate
on five percent of the change sure just
let me I just I don't want to have to go
lollipops for Life yeah dude I want some
checks with my new address on it and I
want some change I just I don't know
where to take it yeah you got to go to
what you're gonna have to do is I take
mine put in a safe deposit to my mom's
house real fancy but I can't think of
the Colorado no no I know but I'm just
saying you go to if you go to a Suburban
a Suburban Supermarket because they
still have them so I might what I might
do is while we're renovating out in
Jersey I might get a zip car there you
go and then drive it
[Laughter]
if anybody gets close give them the
business yeah got the pinkertons with
you yeah I'm like [__] it you shoot them
the second they ride up on me what about
the new spot yeah give it give us give
us the scoop now I know you were you
were out in Astoria for a long time I
was in a story for 15 years you were
famously one of the people used like
look at Soder he's still living with
Becky out dude in an old subway car yeah
we love the theory we lived in a we just
lived for stand up it was like living at
the boxing gym it was incredible because
I could wake up in the morning and after
like doing like three sets than I before
be like am I do this joke and vacuum
will be like no or like yeah someone
does something similar and you're like
all right bouncing bits and stuff it was
great it was great but yeah I lived in
Astoria I moved to Hoboken when I first
moved out here I lived on a buddy's
couch for like seven months then I moved
to my apartment under the train and that
was it for so long for 15 and a half
years crazy you were on television a lot
I've done five seasons
you must have done five seasons
yeah I did five seasons of billions I
did five seasons uh I did five years of
the bonfire and I had been touring
non-stop since 2012. and I just that's
crazy they like to stay on the streets
near the people there wasn't a reason my
my landlord wasn't raising the rent it
was a comfortable apartment sure it was
basically a two and a half bedroom
because I lived in the half bedroom for
seven years but
it was 10 minutes from LaGuardia that's
big 30 minutes from JFK
I could ride the train into the city
I didn't need which was wild I went
there once to film something I think in
the in the pandemic and I had heard
about this apartment yeah and I was like
there's no way this is it it was you
could literally you could jump from the
second floor onto the train track yeah
it was one of the ones where if if you
kept the windows open in the spring it
was the train coming and it's you know
it was the end it was the NQ it was a
popular train line NW and WQ talking
about the app or anything it's just it's
just Street Road Track the G train get
out of here we're talking elevated we're
talking a main line and it was like
multiple cars always had construction
too always and you just hear
like slowing stop and I would go outside
and smoke dude I when I was smoking
cigarettes I'd be on the phone with my
mom and like she would just know I'd be
like train and she'd just shut up shut
up
all right we're good what's up
and it didn't bother me it bothered the
women I dated more than it bothered me
you think yeah I don't care yeah I know
but that's do you guess what didn't
bother Katie and look who I'm married
yeah hey shout out to a real one shout
out to her at some point you definitely
look at Paul Giamatti or like my
roommate's pretty tight yeah I was like
my roommate will single leg take down
you don't you come for me or Mike
Vecchio don't [__] your [__] up
live by the train but yeah he's like why
would you live now but it is uh I loved
it I didn't mind it and then pandemic
happened and yeah I remember you moved
out with uh Mike's Katie moved in was
like okay she's gonna come stay with us
and my kid he was out in Jersey in her
apartment by herself I was like well
I'll come out there and then we got a
dog and then it just you know and that
was it so you were there and now you
guys are moving into the city I remember
you telling me about this yeah so we
would we've been looking to move into
the city for a while and then finally we
just found a place by you guys like two
blocks away from here right and
undisclosed location undisclosed
location but it was it was it's awesome
we're like in the process of moving in
right now and I've never I lived in
Manhattan kind of covet I found a real
good I remember that we had just I think
that was one of your last no that's when
Katie did it you were going to move
you're like yeah he was moving in we
were moving out we were moving out and
Katie like his owner apartment or
whatever and I was like listen I'm
comfortable living with you but I don't
want to feel like it this wasn't a
decision like this had to happen right
vecchione and his girlfriend with your
quarters yeah I did I was like hey where
do you keep the quarters but it was a
thing where vecchion and Katie his
girlfriend moved in together and then I
got a [__] deal a deal that I was
like it was on 23rd and park and I was
like I remember that I was like there's
no way I'll ever be able to get a deal
this good and the the real estate guy
was like this is one of the last covet
deals I've seen in the city of like if
this is a coveted deal like take this
and so I was like yeah he's like but the
problem is it's a it's a 10-month lease
and I was like that's weird and then I
saw why because after the 10 months
they're like so we're gonna go back to
the original price and it was 45 extra
of what I was playing yeah so I was like
yeah [__] this this isn't even that nice
little apartment and but I didn't stay I
stayed at I stayed with Katie though you
weren't home that whole time because her
and the dog were out there sure and so
like I I would stay at the apartment
sometime like she weren't she went and
did the Olympics for NBC so she had to
go up to Connecticut I stayed in the
apartment then it was cool but this is
like us first place together before no
one else had lived there you're in there
uniting and you said you guys you're
keeping the place out there and you're
gonna rent it out yeah yeah that's why
we got this place there you go but it's
like and you're renting this place yeah
we're renting this place we wanted to do
a year or two in the city to be like
let's live I like it I just live in the
city before we go to The Burbs let's
[__] do it there you go and so I you
know and then of course I left my radio
job right as we did that
I had a salad
I'm in a doorman building you said yeah
dude it's crazy I'm too nice all right
do you feel we you have to I've I'd have
never lived I've had to stop myself
twice could dirt bags come from the same
cloth yeah I would try to hold the door
for him I have had to stop myself twice
from
offering to get him something at Dwayne
Reed when I'm going across the street
yeah
so I did that the first time you want
these guys in your pocket I know well
you want them to like it because they
never kill a hooker
they're like well they're like Miss
Katie won't even know that she was on Mr
Dan you buy me coffee yeah uh you give
me a ginger ale once every three weeks
but I this I uh like you know eight or
nine years ago I dated this wealthy
girls the first girl I ever dated that
lived in a a toy man building and I did
I was like Hey I'm going to CVS you want
anything and he was like
he got weird she's like don't do that
yeah I was like is that bad
they make you use a service entrance I
did I really I would have felt more
comfortable yeah to go through some
weird stained glass doors he's got a
jumpsuit on like he's there to fix
something yeah I go I'll ride up in the
service elevator those are my people
when you guys moved in you used a moving
company yeah so that was all done but
did they did the door guys have to do
anything they did great did you grease
this guy did you grease them when you
got in there to set the tone no throw
them a hundi
grease okay he gotta agree just what
just get just give him a hundred yeah
hey thanks for everything here you guys
for you have him how many years been in
there and maybe give me 100.
we're moving the movers are coming next
Monday oh so you haven't even moved in
yet we have but we've had Furniture
delivered okay let's coordinating that
she is okay all right and is there
multiple dormant or just the same guy
every day multiple so this so this is
why I haven't greased the door because
when Christmas comes buddy you gotta
grease them now but then yeah you gotta
grease though at a nice place I used to
work for rich people and I would have to
tip their their building staff for them
like write the checks and they'll most
buildings will send out oh I know my my
one on Park did they go hey here's this
is for the porters this is for the door
guy this is for the overnight door guy
that's for the super well these are on
the list these are all of our All-Stars
is this a big operation or is there
about three or four guys it's a big
operation it's a big op do you know who
the head guy is you're gonna have to
whack him real quick
now you're running the door I feel like
I'm gonna be a private investigator I'm
gonna go but Katie that's not where the
bus that's not where the buck stops
apparently Julio's involved as well goes
all the way to Carol in the leasing
office and what's that I walked it back
these lobs they don't even open the back
door okay let's talk about Lucy Lucy
Lucy Lucy Lucy yeah talking about some
broad that ice Chan High School hey
we're talking about Lucy Breakers baby
get your nicotine anywhere and
everywhere oh yeah you're allowed to use
Breakers in church at a restaurant or at
your cousin's third wedding ceremony
because you're trashed nobody can tell
you no I know about everything's even
better it's nicotine patch with a
surprise inside Lucy Breakers have tiny
capsules that burst open to unleash
delicious flavors like mint mango Berry
and my personal favorite I like the
espresso you don't want to be getting
your uh your nicotine pouches at the gay
station like a dirt ball no no you want
whenever you need a little uh kick in a
pants a little uh grip of the balls
there you pop one in bada Binga [__]
jammed up let's cut let's talk dirty
yeah you start soaring baby you're back
against the wall shout out to Luke
Lucy breakers for 15 off your Breakers
check out the website and subscribe and
save option your Lucy products are
delivered right to your door so you'll
never be empty-handed give yourself a
little little surprise when life feels
overwhelming you deserve it we know you
do uh so visit uh l-u-c-y dot Co Lucy
dot Co use promo code garbage you get 20
off your first order shipping is always
free that's Lucy l-u-c-y dot Co promo
code garbage is free to receive 20 off
and always free shipping here comes the
fine print baby Lucy products are only
uh for adults of legal age and every
order is age verified this product
contains nicotine and nicotine is an
addictive chemical okay let's talk about
Aura Aura talking about digital photo
frames uh-huh real nice yeah get your
own personal slideshow out there
especially for the parents for the
grandparents you send them you shut them
up with pictures of the kids and what
have you and let's not forget Mother's
Days around the corner do yourself a
favor get in one of these Aura frames
they're real nice we got one at the
house all right the bird sister can
upload pics of the kids I know boom
they're right there you see him it's
nice you upload images using a free app
and Wi-Fi you can even have pre-loaded
ones in the frame personalized messages
or embarrassing photos you know
something coming out of the shower oh
maybe a little butthole shot if you
think if you think Denise Mother's Day
if you think Denise ain't getting one of
these frames you get dead wrong and
you're above Zone uh the interactive
touch bar allows you to like photos and
congratulations change images anytime
the gifts you make mean the the gifts
you make mean the most so this year turn
your family's path into the perfect
Mother's Day present with a connected
frame from Aura named the best digital
photo frame by wire cutter and the
strategist strategist you never look at
the photos on your phone no with Laurie
looping around featured in hundreds of
gifts and guides Aura frames are
guaranteed to make your mom or grandma
smile or dad or Grandpa don't don't
discriminate right now Aura has a great
deal for Mother's Day listeners can
visit auraframes.com to get up to thirty
dollars off off their best-selling uh
Carver frames that's Aura Aura
frames.com plus listeners can get free
shipping with the code garbage at
checkout this deal ends May 14th so
don't wait you snooze you lose terms and
conditions apply now back to the show
what's the maintenance guy situation I
don't know I met him briefly
you gotta make sure on moving day yeah
make sure you bang him out because
they're gonna make sure you got the
elevator yes call one of the ladies in
the leasing office to reserve the
elevator cool so I'm on the phone with
them but I gotta agree sir too
she's a salaried employee she's not
boots on the ground anybody boots on the
ground I'm going by the leasing office
they go now I uh I know he said 12
months why don't we make it 14. just
drop a bag of change on the table and
you can take that out to Red Bank
I need that Ziploc back though if you
want to go to New Jersey off Highway 17
there's a horny star I hear there's a
coin star with no lines if you've hit
the if you've hit the West Elm you've
gone through
yeah this is all new it's all new to us
yeah I love it you got to bang that guy
out that day because he's going to make
everything go real smooth all right
he'll make sure you got the parking spot
out front and all that [__] it's gonna
be funny when I walk up and I go my
friend told me I have to bang you out
now you want to do this in my place or
yours sir I do not have sex with people
who live here I go oh oh okay I see how
that came off that at least doesn't
actually start until next week so you
know okay yeah so it's been it's been
fun like that's all go into sets like
tonight I got sets at the stand just go
down there do it
oh you're walkable it's crazy uh I
walked to therapy today wow it's crazy
I'm so excited we got a king-sized bed
that's big that's the first time for a
New Yorker king size bed the first ever
king size bed first ever really big
that's you look out
oh and is she caught her back in the
decor and all that stuff she I took care
of the bed she took care of everything
else nice have you eaten in the bed yet
no we haven't even slept in the bed yet
tonight's gonna be our first night but I
like where your head's at
we'll we'll be munching we have big we
have we have big I bought a big like uh
tray thing for my old apartment we'll be
eating on that in the bed nice what uh
what What's the kitchen looking like you
got stainless steel yeah it's not that
like crazy nice it's nice but it's not
like it's not like a holy [__] it's
close it's close to I love it we gotta
we're we're high up so we got a good
view that's awesome like when I went to
Jay when Jay moved into his place like
two years ago like dirt like right
during the pandemic
I was floored by his view yeah he's
downtown right no he's up on he's on the
West Side he's on and I just love oh I
knew that I love a view that's where my
it's all right all right I just love I'm
a simple man feel better dude I'm a very
simple boy let me stare out at something
a little bit of sun on my face Katie's
got a view of the city of her apartment
in Jersey and I'm like I just stare at
it and she's like she's like what what
is that yeah I'm like that's so cool I
know you're staring next to a [__]
train I was under yeah I was looking at
train I mean the legs of a train I know
of trains
by name I miss my friends
guy falls in love and he ain't the same
if it gets where he came from a pigeon
with one leg oh dude I miss those
pigeons I missed the lady dude I went
and did um
where did I go I was in Astoria for
something I was doing stops podcast
and I was like the king of the story I
was like I'm gonna walk back to the
train I had to get it coming to the city
so I was like I'll walk to my old train
stop and there's the Dunkin Donuts and
baby I saw the Indian ladies pop for me
they used to love me dude I would go to
that Dunkin Donuts every day sometimes
twice a day and I'd come in there
hey and they knew medium coffee medium
iced coffee two creams that is new every
time and I hadn't seen that woman in two
years and I walked in and she went well
hello it was touching I was like hey
that's a New York moment I was like how
you been and she was like good what
she's like where are you and I was like
I live in New Jersey now but I went I
saw a friend here and she's like oh okay
and then we you run out of conversation
yeah right away yeah you think yeah yeah
okay but dude I mean I was that was my
Dunkin Donuts for 15 years I used to get
to Duncan run up the stairs if the train
was there
I hated Duncan are you a Starbucks are
you a Duncan Duncan but there's just a
Starbucks right by us yeah Duncan's in
New York you're in the city now what are
you doing bugs there is like a cool
coffee place that I saw called like Rays
or something that I was like oh I'll
have to go give that a try but it's
crazy being in the city there's there's
Dwayne Reed two blocks away from that
you're just in there hanging out I was
buying something hey we need anything I
really didn't have the thought when I
was buying something the other day where
I was like probably gonna get to know
everyone that works here
a regular Duane Reade yeah you're doing
Sam those birthday cards are looking
stock
hey got the Easter stuff in already yeah
oh yeah 50 off huh it's like get that
bunny the [__] out of here anyways who's
working the register today you know you
made it when the deodorant's not locked
up oh they give you the key God damn we
trust you here's a little red team yeah
imagine having your own key I would love
that dude keys to the place
you're a good kid I'm gonna go get these
gillettes I'll go get these raisins dude
everything's damn watch the register I
gotta run I gotta run and take a piss
real quick I got you I go what's up you
have a phone number with us
yeah I mean yeah apparently you're doing
pretty well dude the one in Queens man
everything's locked up literally
everything is locked up really every
single thing is locked you gotta hit
button for everybody oh then they're
like mad at you I feel like oh yeah I'm
like I feel like I'm knocking on their
apartment door being like hey can you
help me get deodorant yeah I just want
toothpaste I know and they're like dude
you want the enamel cleaner you're like
yes please of course getting the
Sensodyne yeah that's how you know
you're getting old because when you get
super jacked for like uh like almost
pharmaceutical break I don't even need a
prescription for now oh look at all the
benefits of what it does bulletproof
dude it literally does but when you're a
kid you're like can it be made of candy
can I get a sugar in it yeah cookies and
cream toothpaste and now you're like hey
what uh what are the dentists using
Now is awesome I use my nieces and
nephews not that long ago put it on
toast
he's just side huffing it it was like
Laffy Taffy girls school you go sorry I
got a lot of cine crystals in my in
between my teeth feels like I'm chewing
on Sand yeah when you guys since you
guys have had money do you guys like uh
have you gone to like a nicer dentist a
nice toothbrush
I've been to the dentist in about 10
years yeah maybe longer what you go
regularly once I started going dude
you're in I went in Queens I found a guy
yeah on on Groupon yikes that was my my
wife got me a one on Groupon and I went
and it was such a scam dude they tried
up selling me for like full set of
braces for my mouth and my legs I didn't
have any money so it was a hundred
dollars for a cleaning and the guy
that's what I got and the guy was like
I'll toss in x-rays for like extra 70
bucks and I was like well how can I not
but the Dennis came out and he was so
fake tan and he was wearing like or
scrubs yeah which I was like what are we
doing guy I can understand the white
jacket but were you gonna operate I'm at
the Smile Cafe yeah and I just didn't
trust it I was like this guy he was like
a porn dentist yeah dude that was coming
in being like open wide I'm not even
exaggerating the woman I had was a
[__] Brazilian knockout really
ow she had a dress on with this with the
with the white jacket over it and she's
like you need to do this and this and
this and I was I had my checkbook out
ready to go there you go give me all new
teeth whatever you say Miss will you
like me if I have all your teeth and
she's leaving you like a guy with nice
seats yeah ah tell you then she goes yes
dude just leaning it was
now my dentist I felt because my wife
got it for me it felt like a setup
where's your dentist now
in the city in Midtown look at them
right well I got one because tell him
nothing The Producers on the bonfire had
one that was like across the street and
I was like oh that'll be great so I can
just go to the dentist and be right here
at work so I still use her she's too
cool she's like hey what's up bro no
she's like looking good I'm like really
because one tooth feels like it hurts
and she was like nah that's just you
being a puss nutshack
no she's just like very careful with the
ball tap yeah she's very casual about it
she's like no you're fine and you're
like I'm fine she's like yeah I'm like
I'm gonna go on the road and eat a lot
of candy
have some for me that's a good dinosaur
that's one of the reasons why I'm also
lazy and scared to go yeah but so
everyone in Queens just looks like they
they also sell like insurance policies
well they're like they're like in the
apartment building type thing yeah
there's there's an orthodontist in my
apartment building well the one I went
to in Queens with the [__] porn tan
was in just a house yeah on 24th Avenue
I don't want to smell soup when I walk
in there yeah you don't like walking
it's like the waiting rooms the sun room
yeah and then you're like in the living
room with the there's a kid running
around dude I just didn't like it I was
like asking me what I did while I was
like his hands were in my mouth I'm like
let's not do this right now yeah they
have the old kid toys in there like
those little weird things yeah
all creeped out huh you would think you
know what's weird is dentists are hated
by children
but the amount of pedophiles of dentists
pretty well so low compared for how
they're feared for what how they're
feared by kids priests should be a lot
more feared I think definitely taking a
lot have had a I have had a tough road
and I think children need to apologize
to dentists you know why there's there's
probably not a lot of pedophilia in
Dennis because those guys are getting
[__] laid you know why are they what
well here's the thing young Dennis they
always have a hot [__] dental
hygienist they get a hot Dental digest
so it goes one of two ways the good way
it breaks with dentists they're
attractive you know they're like young
cool dudes they got hot dental
hygienists I don't even know how you say
that word but you got it they like have
like an assistant you know like a like a
magician that's hot and then they bang
her now the evil dentists
put you to sleep and touch you when
you're under
so you don't know how to file what's his
number there's two sides of a coin
you're gonna get assaulted by this guy
but you're just probably gonna be asleep
and then you wake up and you're like
what happened Yeah Tim Whatley yeah yeah
sometimes I talk yeah yeah it is you're
like that's the thing I worry about
Dennis is then putting you under it yeah
you have dental insurance or you pay out
of pocket Insurance damn this guy's sag
Afters right right right I need a
cleaning stat couple x-rays oh man you
get that white strips get my head on
straight you know what's the message you
get that cleaning I don't know about you
guys but I go home and I look in the
mirror and I go and I suck the air
through my teeth and it feels good it's
like it's like it's like chewing a nice
piece of gum yeah yeah
look at all that space yeah because
normally it's just filled with plaque oh
yeah dude between the coffee and the
Bernies I'm [__] oh my God I'm done
are you flossing every day never no see
I floss every day I'm on top of it yeah
I'm not working out right now I gotta
start working out Dental it goes cardio
yeah yeah yeah weight lifting yeah I get
winded go walking upstairs I need to get
the cardio back then I'll take care of
the Chompers oh that's funny
um well buddy we're so happy for you
yeah that's great you're a full-grown
boy now man it's wild it's wild to live
in the city it's pretty cool yeah any
amenities got gym in the building
it's time to lose these yeah what about
uh these and this is there a game room
or anything like that there is a cool
like um
well it's funny is there's like you can
rent a space yeah like the common space
sure yeah like a birthday party but then
they have like a place in the basement
that's like really just common like you
can just go down there and work okay
Wi-Fi or whatever
which you never will we already I did
use it when we didn't have our furniture
in in St Germain and I were working on
something and I was like we can we can
meet in the city and we were we had been
going like Starbucks and [__] and I was
like let's go to my new building you're
gonna sit in the basement and work but
what happened is I tried to run you guys
who feel comfortable in the basement
underground also two guys
who don't look like they should be in
that building
supposed to be working right now say
jermain's like oh I don't know man I
crawled in through a water
a day he always has the energy of Ace
Ventura when he comes out of the Rhino
that's that's I love him that's Saint
Germain and then there's constant Vibes
me over explaining being like actually
it's okay but we uh we we did that and
then but what's funny is there is a
place you can rent out
like that's like a workspace and so how
did we just signed the lease and I
called and I knew I had to meet up with
Saint Germain and I was like all right
and so I called the building and I was
like I can't look at reserve it two
people for like four hours and she was
like great great great great great
um just gonna need the payment and I was
like what do you mean payment she's like
well this this like space on one of the
floors like costs money and I was like
oh how much does it cost she's like 125
an hour yeah I'm good we I don't what I
can just go to the basement and work
she's like hey you can just go to the
basement I was like yeah I'll go to the
basement who the [__] paying 100.
every once in a while dude you know what
though you know what I don't work though
you know what I like about to work about
my building is there's old people in my
building
the building I got the covet deal on all
young people and that makes you feel
like [__] because you're like how do you
afford to [__] I can I was on five
seasons of a TV show yeah what are you
doing yeah yeah yeah it's all parents
money sure this one's nice because it's
like you see an old man and you're like
yeah all right buddy look at us huh look
at us living in the city Mr wilmingham
good to see you exactly flirt with the
wife a little bit
your skin isn't as see-through today
I can't see your heart beating through
your wrists
I'm bad at Charming old people
remember when you thought we shouldn't
get involved in World War II
how do you feel now
uh but uh all right well we got to do
some patreon questions it's always fun
having Danny shows in the building
um but guys as you know when you sign up
for patreon we will answer your garbage
questions on the air uh this one's from
Chester drawers chest of drawers you
ever try to suck up spill drinks or food
off the table like you're a vacuum yeah
all the time dude soda off the kitchen
counter as a kid yeah it's a little
different oh my god dude
or like chocolate milk or if you really
wanted to get crazy if you had a straw
you could you could do that and then
watch the science of it all yeah yeah
because when your face is too close
you're dipping your nose in you know
when you're getting like a full like
that but when you got the straw you can
yeah you get to see it all in action man
it was all right would you be uh would
it be a serious thing if you spilled at
dinner or something like that if you
knocked out as a kid I'm a spill I'm a
spilly boy dude as a kid would you get
yelled because my dad used to react like
his wife yeah yeah like it was explosive
freak out my mom Jesus Christ can't have
anything nice we're at a diner shut up
it's in public yeah at home it was the
explosive like oh
and then my mom would be like don't
don't it's all right just stop you know
and you're like because you somehow make
it worse yeah you're picking a place
yeah
I mean spilling wasn't uh
it wasn't like a hittable offense but it
was sure it was it was it was like oh
[__] oh oh save this it would ruin
dinner on Sunday my my dad would be
cooking for like an hour or so get
everything all set up nice and [__] I
would just knock over a glass thing
[__] Jesus Christ oh dude I lose it
oh my God I would spill at my friend's
house which is the worst oh that sucks
you want to see the parents sometimes
the parents don't give you the it's okay
you see the frustration you're like when
your friend's parents are dicks for the
first time you're like whoa Middle
School I wasn't allowed I wasn't allowed
I was the only friend of my buddies that
wasn't allowed to eat outside of the I
was I wasn't allowed to eat outside of
the kitchen at your buddy's house yeah
everyone else was allowed to like have
pizza go sit on because they had like a
nice house and I would still you lost
your privileges dude and then one time I
was sleeping over and he had a hideaway
bed you know that went under his trundle
a trundle bed and I was sleeping on the
trundle bed and I was holding a Dr
Pepper and we were fighting over the
remote and he let go and
I just dumped Dr Pepper all over me and
he was like my mom's gonna be so pissed
and I had to wash his sheets before his
parents woke up Jesus Christ they had
that no I don't know damn what do you do
I told I told his mom I have done a lot
of whites anybody got anything yeah hey
Donna Gary you guys got socks anything
you need me to throw in there uh cold
water I don't want to wake you guys up
but this spin cycle is about to be
pretty intense oh [__] my mom knows when
when sun touches her washing machine
dude all I knew is I was like I'll
figure this out because this is and then
I told her later as an adult and she was
like you always spilled and I was like
that wasn't my fault
that wasn't my [__] fault uh-huh I
was bad man it sucks you smelled a lot
my child every time I went to the
Suburban Diner I spilled my chocolate
milk and my dad made he would hit the
diner table which makes such a specific
noise yeah the plates clattering the
whatever Jesus and I'm like now looking
back I'm like relax man yeah but they
didn't now we're like [__]
Bloomingdale's they didn't have Edibles
they don't have a lot of stuff that were
released I get it because of my niece or
my nephew does some [__] like that at
dinner I [__] but that's just because
I lose it but that's just because you're
wired that way yeah
because people lost it on you yeah you
go oh when something it's bad but I
think the sentiment or the idea behind
it obviously you don't want to lose it
but you want the kids to know how to act
at a restaurant or out in public and if
they're [__] knocking over [__] and
acting yelling there's other people
that's different I got a spill on a
drink versus yelling or horses horseplay
to table I don't co-sign
absolutely not have you both waited
tables yes have you
you're in the [__] more than a waiter
sure I was waiting tables five years ago
tables last week Dan
yeah you're gonna pick up a shift after
this time I'm gonna wrap this up
soder's long-winded yeah I think this
guy's got voices and stories
they uh I'll catch the swing shift did
you ever did you ever wait on a table
where the kids were making a mess and
they didn't care and the parents didn't
stop them yeah I only did like at nicer
restaurants he probably was in the city
countless times yeah towards the end of
my tenure at Bareburger I had a real bad
situation where I was close to the point
where if I said [__] it and walked out I
maybe would have been okay because I was
hosting a lot at New York sure at New
York comedy club so maybe I was okay and
I always had that in the back of my head
and for the 15 years that I waited
tables that's the dream yeah [__] this
[__] throat I used to jerk off to
that oh and I had this I talk about it
all the time I had this study group from
NYU that would come in like every
Wednesday and they were there were you
at the Bareburger over on LaGuardia
which one that was yeah that's a tough
that's a tough draw dude yeah you got
NYU traffic no man you always got to
look around because if I was thinking
like Bareburger Astoria I'm like how you
dealing with no people you know real
people no this was something of the
Earth yeah a lot of people were great
but some of those NYU kids and faculty
because you're right there you're at NY
and they weren't paying for it was one
Professor painted so these other
professors they were such [__]
[__] like would just I'd be taking
an order
at the table next to them they would
come in and walk right up to me and be
like hey can I get this and it's just
like dude and you're doing that on those
days
so I could do it right there but it
[__] up the flow you know how it is
we really want to tell a teacher it's
great to tell a teacher you go sit down
oh sit down I will I will talk to you
when I am ready I really I really
[__] sort of let go nothing is better
than a waiter on their way out oh man
not given a [__] money when I was in
Midtown I'd be like like at the end of
my dos Camino's career I'd be like oh
you didn't get your guacamole well who
gives a foreign
yeah dude had a guy like it like like a
a wealthy guy with his kids and you
could tell his kids grow up with a
little bit of cash because they knew
like Truffles and they knew they knew
all that's crazy and if you don't know a
chocolate truffle if you know what a
real truffle is yeah kid you got mine I
don't even need a smack but this kid
ordered something and I specifically
went over what it was and he said yeah I
want that and like first of all he's
talking to me like I'm a [__] jerk
off it wasn't going through the dad it
was going the kid was [__] talking
they're like annoyed with you yeah like
being a [__] this fat man's looking
at me and uh I'm about to sneeze yeah
and I go back and I come back and he's
like he doesn't like this he's like he
didn't know that it had this on and I'm
like I told him it did dude I [__]
told you that it did and I'm like okay
well you know can I get this and you
know the table that's that just is a
dick to be a dick oh yeah so let me take
it back and I'll get one free no don't
worry no it's fine Donna won't eat it
now you're just gonna ruin it more yeah
exactly and the guy [__] stiffed me
and it was like a [__] 200 Bill and
they just left all their [__] thrown on
the [__] table man it was it was it
was one of the straws I did end up
walking out of there right it was one
day I just [__] walked out I don't
think you lost I don't know I think I
waited till the shift I think you were
asked to stop coming in to be no not
that one that was the other place
insane that just tip you you have to
make such a [__] conscious effort to
not tip oh yeah yeah the Europeans you
let them get away with it a little bit
but they know they know sometimes though
you would like I remember I was working
like Cafe season it was crazy and I was
working I was working at dinner shift
because I had zero money and I was I
just these European these two European
women I want to say Eastern European
just I knew they weren't going to tip me
so I was talking very fast I could tell
that I couldn't understand English and
like by the end I was like here's a
check you two weren't bad but I know
you're not gonna tell me so God bless
have a good night or whatever I went
back they tipped me 40 like they heard
they knew what I was saying and I was
like you feel like such a [__] yeah
you're like oh but I've had I've had
people that
the worst people are the people that
tell you they're [__] you over with
the tip
and then they tell you that normally
they they are very good tippers sure
there's that there's also where they're
like normally I don't normally do this
yeah this will [__] you this woman came
in
um right as we opened because I was a
lunch waiter I only did lunch shifts you
know sometimes yeah if you I could walk
with like 100 I could walk with a
hundred 110. you're leaving at four or
five o'clock five o'clock right out in
the spring summer I'd go home hey can
you stay no we're gonna go home wash my
face in my neck I take a 10 minute nap
and then I'd go do sets like a detective
yeah I seriously would like put water on
him
right here that's the wall
yeah and then I'd go lay down for 10
minutes I'd get up put your gun back in
the drawer
and then I I mean I'd wake up
rip a camel light on the way to Duncan
see the Indian gals grab a coffee jump
on the train and come home but uh I
remember this woman came in right as we
opened and she sat at the bar they're
like seating's not open yet and the
woman's like it's fine I'll just eat at
the bar so she ordered a Cobb salad
um and then the calf I was I was closing
lunch on the cafe so I had the best
section at the front of the cafe and um
there's like a little two top side side
thing or whatever so I'm like waiting
I'm like polishing my silverware setting
everything up and then this woman just
sits down
she's like one of these older women
that's like in her 70s with brand new
tits like brand new fake like they were
like high and tight or whatever I like
that and uh she was just real like Upper
East Side energy
and she just sat in my section and I was
like oh hi can I help you and she goes
yeah I was in the bar but I want to sit
outside and I was like oh did you talk
to a Hostess and she was like
what
and she like brought her and uh I was
like oh okay well
the bartender is your server I [__]
hate that so I was like I don't know
what you want me to do and she's like
and then the bartender's like I uh the
girl was like I I transferred the ticket
to you and I was like oh thanks and so I
drop her Cobb salad off
and then it's a lunch rush you get hit
sure you know what it is you get like
you get double sat next thing you know
your whole second son it is all or
nothing all it's very stressful to be a
lunch waiter in New York and if they're
if the place isn't properly staffed
there is no way that you can do the
whole Spiel that they want you to do
they want you to do a lot of steps to
service they're all in a rush I got to
go back
40 minutes okay bring the check right
away realistic expectations always and
they always have the energy of and I
understand this they want to eat faster
that they have a little extra time to
themselves and we're at the we're at the
base of a very big office but you're not
dealing you're not [__] you might not
have the kitchen unlocked it might be
the [__] guy behind the in the
kitchen that doesn't like you that's not
going to get your [__] fast or they
order Margaritas bartender's running
behind because he's they're slammed the
food hits a table before the drinks
freak out or the guacamole is taking a
while because guacamole was like their
big thing and there was like a guac bar
with all these like Teenage that were
just working for hourly just mashing
avocados so my section fills up
immediately
immediately and so stop I can't really
give this lady any attention but I keep
going by being like all right yeah all
right and she's like eating her Cobb
salad finally she goes can I just get my
check like that and I was like
uh yeah everything all right and she's
like I would like to talk to a manager
and I was like uh okay but first I want
this salad boxed up and also there's no
pinto beans on this and
you should know your your menu because
norm and I oh I said uh well there's no
beans on that salad and she goes yes
there are you should learn your product
there's shake the order lady that's
exactly what I thought and she goes so I
want pinto beans and I was like oh you
want some pinto beans on that to box up
and she was like yeah some dingleberries
so I was friends with I was friends with
the line Cooks you gotta be because you
get tapped in you gotta be I was friends
with the chef and so I went downstairs
and I was like Hey Chef it was right
it's like you know lunch rush is
building and I go can I get a bowl of
steamed pinto beans like a cartoonishly
large bowl and I just took this bowl of
pinto beans and dumped it on her salad
and boxed it up and then tied it tied in
the to-go bag and I brought it to her
and then she like showed me the check
and she did that she goes normally I'm a
very good Tipper but you weren't nice to
me and I was like well you weren't my
table and she was like are you also
wearing nice ladies it's a two-way
street dumb [__] dude and she tipped me
uh six cents oh and she went like next
time be nicer and you should get a
better tip and it just ruined that shift
that [__] sucked dude how long ago
was that uh 12 years ago and you're
thinking about it right now I need to go
smoke a cigarette midshift I looked at
my manager I go hey if you want me to be
useful at all I gotta go rip a butt I
gotta go get you and I'll just go stand
next to the super Runner shop and have
the Russian guy come out and go do no
smoke in front of the store and I'd go
[__] you dude if I was in the weeds man
if I was in a mood dude it didn't come
out I would just talk [__] to him I mean
what do you want me to stand [__]
Taco Bell cause there's a Taco Bell
right there and he's like I don't know
get out of the way and then I'd come
back in and the managers at the
pre-shift meeting would be like some of
you guys are standing in front of the
Super's Runner shop when you're smoking
you can't do that
and especially when guys are like
there's people that are [__]
thinking they're proving a point well
you're like you're not proving a point
you're just being a [__] to a guy
that's that doesn't want to be here I
never understood that we always we were
taught to like we're we're in their way
like as kids because I think it's a very
blue collar thing of like hey man
everybody every blue collar person at
some point has weighted tables or
something or whatever worked in the
service industry everybody should so
it's like they know and so we were like
I felt like we were always taught like
you're infringing upon them like they're
jammed up I still haven't they have to
yeah hey when you get it you get two
iron workers
yeah Blue Collar guys would come in and
be like what do you like and you're like
enchiladas and like hey give us two of
those yeah and then you bring them like
Coronas or whatever and then hear
another table talking to you like they
like look at you they go what about
those [__] yeah yeah and you go you
go I know right they [__] suck
they're the best you know who is the
[__] man was um uh Mort from ESPN
Chris Mortensen
he was good he came in and I was like
empty section and he was just by himself
and he's like what's good I was like
steak tacos [__] Rule and he was like
I'll get those and it was the 49ers were
like really bad they were like two and
fourteen and I was like how then what's
going on with the Niners and he's like
man I don't know he's like you can sit
down and I just sat there was an empty
section so I just sat down see at the
table next you start looking for a
waiter oh okay I don't know where these
guys are
the famous people were always the
coolest always Sarah Jessica Parker cool
as [__] Bradley Cooper yeah just me and
him in the restaurant really cool as
[__] I had um I had Martina McBride
awesome nice Tori Amos awesome nice Bam
Margera so great really shout out to Bam
I know he's got a lot of troubles I hope
he's all right because he was really
[__] cool Damon Wayans oh really
[__] you tell me did comedy
[Laughter]
you know who I waited on as a young uh
not young but as a as an open mic
has an open mic here in New York City a
little spot in the West Village came in
with an executive from Comedy Central
Mr Dan Soder really yeah really and you
sniffed them on a tip you and you and
Saint Germain
you were with Brooke posh
when this was [__] 2013
2014 Jermaine and I yeah and you weren't
together she had come in and had
meetings with both these separately [__]
she was [__] cool as [__] yeah man I
never told her
uh snack to Vern in the West Village oh
yeah Bedford and Morton yeah [__]
unbelievable food yeah unbelievable that
was uh when we did our half hours that's
why we were there because Saint Germain
and I did our Comedy Central presents
yeah doing a chicken sandwich and a
bottle of boilings that's me baby I love
boys
all over a bottle of boiling's ginger
ale okay that [__] [__] rules dude
nothing like a lifetime pothead trying
to piece of memory back together and
then getting rocked by some boilers I
love it dude the second you say it I go
I know I know I remember that yeah it
was a balmy spring day yeah that was
always that was always weird the worst
one waiting tables was
um I just remember being like oh man
look at
it oh really yeah what do you mean
that's awesome I remember Fielding
[Music]
I spilled he didn't finish it but I did
um I remember being like
so pumped when famous people would come
in
like you'd be like oh we're gonna be
friends or whatever like I waited on
Vince Neil and he stunk sure he got
hammered he has to start no it's like
afternoon and he's got a hammer yeah
he's like you got my tequila I was like
I don't know I don't know I was so
excited I was like dude [__] Motley
Cruz in the house yeah they suck it's a
heartbreaker and then you're like oh but
I do remember the worst one was
a girl I went to college with that was
in like the popular girl sorority that
[__] my roommate okay she was like a
mean girl
and she was on like a one of eight it
was an eight top on the cafe all blacks
and you're waiting you're waiting tables
I'm in my All Blacks sweat long sleeve
black shirt long sleeve slash things
going good I swear to God because you
were like yeah eight top all black yeah
I was like no I was like what the [__]
where'd he go racist no I was in my I
was wearing all black atop All Blacks I
go well who approved this I thought you
were talking about the new the New
Zealand [__] Rugby teams they're
doing their [__] hakka no there was I
was in okay I was in I was in long
sleeve black shirt long sleeve black
slacks a couple things on that yeah long
black apron nothing was worse than you a
waiter it was like the first you could
see you were the first table and they're
already in dirty clothes
I know you worked at double yesterday I
go to the coffee station and then you
run the rag under the hot you know like
that yeah you steam it do a little dry
cleaning yeah just a dry cleaning right
there be all right right there dude get
you through and I remember there being
like soda wash your [__] apron oh my
bad because you just have salsa and [__]
all over it it's actually guacamole's
Mexican restaurant [__] yeah dude but
dude I just remember going up to this
eight top and I'm in I'm sweating it's
like summer sure and they're there and
just this girl goes
wait a minute
did you go to the University of Arizona
and I'm like
yeah and she's like were you roommates
with a mirror and I was like hey Lauren
let's cut to the Chase and she goes so
what are you up to and I went this like
that I'm taking it and I said it in such
a defeated way that this one of the
dudes at the at the atop was like oh
just the way I said it I go she goes so
what are you up to and I go this like
that and the guy oh [__] [__] [__]
guy yeah dude even if you had stuff
going on you can't really explain it to
them I remember I had a Comedy Central
thing coming up until you have a thing
that everybody knows of like hey
I've done this it doesn't even matter if
it hasn't if it hasn't even done
anything humble beginnings baby oh dude
and then I'm just brutal and like this I
go are you done with that molcajete
clearing stuffer she goes oh my God
remember when you were like I would buy
weed off your roommate and you go are
you done with that thanks let me get
this out of your way for you the worst
one was when I did live at Gotham in
2009 and it was like on Comedy Central
and I was like very
proud of that like it was huge I did it
was on channel 837. wow yeah check the
accessories which is so funny because
everyone that did live at Gotham on
Comedy Central when they did that show
we're like what the [__] dude yeah man
they opened they let anybody on it let
me on that show it was so hard to get
comedy centrals like because that was
their basically premium blend sure that
was their short set but dude I did my
[__] life of Gotham came out it was
in December so we were doing Christmas
parties we get a lot of Christmas
parties
and it was like a [__] 16 top
I was clearing their dishes
and I had this joke about [__] Walmart
it's like one of the jokes I did
and this lady goes [__] Whole Foods too
excuse me she said it out of context
because [__] Whole Foods too and I was
like what's that Miss
and then she's like I watched you on
Comedy Central on Friday and I went well
now you're watching me clear your cup
salad and I just had I remember putting
it in the dish pit and then just like
leaning against the hutch and going like
you ever like make a side that also has
kind of a cry noise you go like okay it
soda just slammed his head into the
guacamole oh my God put his head in the
dishwasher again I will not run it the
African guy's like upset at me oh my God
I hated it I hated it brutal but then
you get to leave when you're away if
you're a waiter right now and you're
watching this the day will come where
you get to leave yeah no matter if it's
for the thing you want to do or not you
will get to end there and just wow
that's very profound that day will come
yes the end comes and it always feels
good feels great even if you're not
leaving for Success feels great even if
you're just leaving yeah when the day I
left those Caminos you know in the
locker room downstairs so I had like all
this stuff in my locker like shoes that
I had worn in a while whatever and I put
them in at the go bag I had the bag and
my buddy Carlos was bartending close and
I walked up the steps where I was and I
showed him the bag and I just went you
do two days it's just like the wire he
was like
you have fun
guys did you [__] last Chopper out of
Nam going to see about a girl quitting
waiting tables December
I think it was December 14th 2011. about
my last day oh God that was so good
that's good mine was May 17th yeah
something like that and you you don't
forget it no because you're like dude I
don't ever want to go because the
restaurant had really gone downhill at
that point too and it was a [__]
nightmare yeah and I [__] hated it oh
you get a new general manager or
something yeah that'll Jam you up jams
you the [__] up we don't do that here
you go I had a nice little polish yeah
oh yeah nice little life here
with the auditions and stuff like that
yeah and it would take two months to
[__] get on the good side of the GM
to be like I I gotta run out I'll come
right back hey I got an audition
tomorrow can I have so-and-so and
[__] dude that [__] would it would it
would change you thought everything was
going to be lost yeah like [__] if I
can't do this I'm gonna have to then you
gotta nothing worse than quitting
sending out the resumes doing that
[__] interview with uh so what are
your steps to service oh your experience
what's your first approach like and
having to fake it for the first couple
of months because it always just settles
into normal dude you're doing coke with
the bartender you [__] once you're
here this guy you know that guy once
you're you're just sipping a little you
know little cone of coke you're not
carrying yeah that's not my table start
drinking start drinking yeah yeah dude
we get caught we'd have frozen
margaritas and you'd purposely I'd
purposely order wrong I go oh you didn't
want the Frozen pomegranate I'm so sorry
and then I'd be like hey Christy they
ordered a lime I put in Frozen I put it
I put in the one I like okay these go to
the hutchinard
just have a little bit of a headache but
then you're like oh I feel chatty I
think you're like sitting there going
through the menu with someone you go you
know it's really good right there you're
like oh you see me get out of here dude
a 2 p.m buzz and a lunch rush bro yeah
dude I'll fold your napkins
I don't know if you don't [__] I don't
give a [__] working at a restaurant with
a loose void policy
that's all right I remember some of our
guys were getting nuts and they were
like they were taking bills right if the
if the tip wasn't good especially during
the Euro boom of 08 if they got like
tipped like 10 or 15 they would go and
void stuff off the check to make that to
make whoa so they would expect that
that's credit card fraud
no no no no I don't know how they would
do it but they would somehow do it where
they would remove a couple things and
like the 10 bucks would go to them or
whatever the 12 bucks would just be in
the tip they were just like respect they
would like found and I was always such a
[__] that I was like I'm not good at
math I don't know how that would work
you know the Europeans when they would
leave you the uh the coins oh you knew
they were on their way to the airport
yeah get like [__] two dollars
[__] the second Julia coins 50th and
third Corner 50th and third where Dos
Caminos was I got a check presenter
filled with change I chased the guy to
the Corner out of the restaurant hey you
forgot this and I dumped it into his
hand good for you and you were no for
you no no no yeah anyway I said I go to
the airport airport or whatever and I
was like well you could take that yeah
because I suck a dick
give that to the people at Hudson News
yeah
leave that in a tray for TSA you [__] uh
all right we gotta run through some cues
here this one yeah this one is uh all
right this one's from Anita Wang how
long I've never thought about this how
long does a carpool or road trip have to
be to ask somebody for gas money over
an hour that's not bad I would say an
hour is like if you're in a car for an
hour that's a drive that's enough and if
it's also age you can't ask at a certain
age anymore you can't be in your that's
a 20s that's got to stop in your 20s
unless let's say you and Jay were
driving somewhere I don't know
somebody's uh if it's road tripping
somebody's getting married in [__] uh
Vermont now that's a gas station that's
gas money I don't want the gas money I
want to be offered to guess or that
might be switch hey you get it now I'll
get it on the way yeah
you pay gas on the way back that I
respect that that's like a very 40s
let's let's have a rational conversation
yeah let's all just kind of make the
effort here is the minimum
is it under an hour for you guys you
can't you're gonna ask somebody if
you're asking somebody
I think it would be for uh well comics
of most of our is for work you know what
I mean so it that hierarchy depends a
little bit on the show like if you're
headlining I'm featuring and he's
hosting that's on you and you're like
Hey we're going out to Soldier if it's
my car I'm driving you'll get the tolls
you'll get the gas yes maybe a nice meal
somewhere yeah maybe stop by a wild
weasel or something yeah we'll pick up
stuff we'll make a day of it let's go
get the sweatshirt somewhere I mean that
was always the pecking order from what I
am sure I still do that when I'm on the
road on Thursday nights because there's
usually one show at the club and then
Friday and Saturday there's two usually
Thursday nights in the city are the
nights that I can go to a restaurant
because it shows over by 9 30 10 o'clock
you can go you can go land somewhere
yeah you can go eat somewhere and I'll
take out the feature in the emcee really
and you pick that up on the cuff yeah
[__] Dan Soder how about that I think
that's standard though you gotta yeah
yeah you know what I mean it's standard
but not everybody does it it's crazy I
hear stories you hear stories on the
road people you know and you're like
damn they don't even [__] tip but
then there's been times where I've
forgotten the tippo Green Room server
and I'm like I get woken up at night
being like are they telling cops we're
religious about it I know but it does it
does it used to be like we would get we
would get the person before the show
Even though we'd be like because you
don't want to you because I don't want
to [__] it up because at the end of the
show you want to leave yeah and then
sometimes you're like I'll I'll forget
about it and he like did you tip I'm
like no I didn't I'm like okay [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] gotta Grease the picture
guy Grease the bartender if you grab a
drink you know off everybody gets
greased everybody yeah yeah yeah but
yeah I mean you can't [__]
if if it's non-comedy and you're like
driving out to the beach or something
like that under an hour yeah you guys
got some gas money I don't think I've
ever asked for gas money in my life
because also an hour drive you should
have enough gas in the car that's a what
a half a tank and get it if you got good
boys they're gonna say something they're
crazy they all get lunch I'll get this
yeah if you're driving out the gas goes
with driving yes you drove out I'll buy
the first round I'll grab lunch yeah you
take care of it falls into the the dirt
if you're had a transpo you get some
free stuff yeah but they're uh I
remember this dude I gave this guy that
I was buddies with a ride from Tucson to
Denver and we went through Las Vegas
like three days yeah we went through Las
Vegas to pick up my friend and his
cousin who lived in Vegas and my buddy
had a full-grown pit bull and he I've
told the story on the bonfire before but
it's it's 100 true he called me and he
was like hey can I get back to Aurora
with you I have no way to get home for
the holidays this was for Christmas and
it's like one of those Christmas movies
where you're like I can't make you stay
out sure then he called me I remember
exactly where I was I was at work I was
at KFMA and he called me and he's like
hey I got my dog and I was like well
that's a problem I'm picking up two guys
in Vegas and he's like he hit a lot of
guns this guy had a lot of guns and
stuff and he goes I don't know what to
do with this dog the dog hotels aren't
picking up he goes
[__] it man I might just take this dog
out to the desert and shoot it and I was
like he like made that offer in a way
where I was like no no no no no no no no
no yeah okay fine now you have blood on
your hands Mr I go you can have a ride
but like you gotta hold that dog the
whole time not sitting in a car for
[__] three days with a dog killer and
he [__] held the dog but he did he uh
he kept talking about how he didn't have
any money so I could that guy for sure
doesn't have money so he like couldn't
help out with gas or whatever but then I
just remember we got we were in St
George Utah and we I got gas and I
filled up the my car with gas and there
was a McDonald's there and this guy
bought like a Big Mac meal super-sized
french fries and was just eating it you
know what I mean and my friend who I
picked up in Vegas goes did you get any
for us and then I went like that and he
goes haha you don't pay for gas but you
can get all that McDonald's respect that
I was like damn because everyone was
over and I felt like such a [__] that I
didn't say something
my [__]
slow that down back to that fancy
dentist man yeah I'm gonna be [__]
like missing a team I've done that on
stage before like as an adult tooth and
I I remember one time I like pulled the
mic out really really quick and it hit
my lip and my lip just started bleeding
where are you from what are you doing
conversational stuff
so you guys uh you guys seeing this new
Rocky movie as I was bombing oh my God
brutal oh my god dude [__] hurting
yourself in a way and trying to act okay
on stage
because you're just not present at all
you're like do they notice it maybe they
are maybe they're not there used to be
this show at the creek in the cave
called uh midnight run yeah they just
get you high as [__] and they were like
macho man died so they were like we want
you to do this whole thing as mushroom
weed and macho man dude they had a they
had a volcano one of the biggest ones I
took like three volcanoes and I was
doing Macho Man and I was like yeah and
I felt me passing out and I was like how
do I get out of this without passing
it was just a bomb and then I remember
getting off stage being like Oh my [__]
it God I almost just passed out it's
brutal uh all right let's see here uh
this one's for Matt at the W 10 homie
ever bought a porn star something off
their Amazon wishlist
but I'll tell you right now if if that
would have been a thing [__] 15 years
ago and I would have had money I would
have done it I can't I don't know I I
don't under I can't make the connection
of like got you that case of water you
wanted yeah you know that you know that
[__] bath light yeah it's just like
real generic daily stuff it's like
diapers and light bulbs I got you I
think a [__] Q-tips yeah
and I don't know what you expect from
that I guess it it's like that you know
is it that like the financial thing of
like you're giving them something it's
the hustle
I guess it makes you feel that much
closer to them do you think they're
gonna [__] you I think they do I I don't
know I don't know it's not my cup of tea
she's like remember when you bought me
that humidifier
probably new air filters now I'm gonna
suck your [__] oh thanks hey thanks
for the Brita filter thanks yeah thanks
Trina star
uh all right this one's from Rob we
could do a few more this one's from
Robert is it garbage if your dad built a
homemade Batting Cage in the backyard
made out of PVC pipe and orange
construction netting though that's right
that's [__] sick it's a dad that
loves you and loves baseball yeah that's
odd dude you would you probably had to
be the [__] best house in the [__]
neighborhood oh my God they were just
going over in [__] cracking balls in
fact dude I'm gonna go to have batting
practice that's so I think there was a
[__] the [__] machine or I think
it was it was coach pitch all right
because that's got to be coach pitch if
he's doing it with orange
in [__] PVC black boys my boy's dad
built a uh [__] Wiffle ball court
like a wiffle ball field in their
backyard really oh it was sick there was
always it became like a thing yeah like
there was like playoffs and [__] it was
wild damn
how much land did he have not that much
it was like a normal backyard and he's
built a [__] just [__] built it
out it was [__] sweet and then that
competition fever starts oh we're going
over we're going over today
dude I remember in college I went like I
got hit soup you know my sophomore year
got really into beer pong like really
into beer like loved it because I'm an
alcoholic and I loved yeah I get it it's
just the best and me and my roommate
were like he didn't like to drink so I
would drink all of his beers and we'd be
playing we were really good you know
because I just get hammered to be like
it was fun yeah and we were like dude
we're gonna have a we're gonna get a keg
we're gonna have a huge tournament
uh try a race board the whole thing the
bracket we bought a big thing like
they're playing in the losers bracket to
find out who's third yeah all that and
it was a 20 Buy in each team sure and it
was 16 teams and we were like dude we're
gonna the winner gets all the money
all this uh we lost in the first round
are you guys gonna wrap this up pretty
soon dude I was so over it I just can't
use the Whiteboard yeah they're like the
finals are going down I was like well
they better not drink all the beer
bottle oh my God I was so pumped the
competition was we were like dude we're
gonna [__] kills and then nope oh
that's [__] all right uh all right
let's do this one then we gotta skid day
at all uh yeah this is from Mike ever
going to the basement and Play the
soundtrack to Mortal Kombat so you could
work on your moves
that's pretty good I never did that but
what I did do
I got robbed in 2004 when I was in
Tucson and instead of working on my
moves now every time I listen to Prodigy
Smack My [__] Up okay I fantasize
the situation going different me taking
the gun yeah and [__] turning on him
yeah where'd you get robbed that they
came in the house yeah they got us Jesus
yeah well my roommate was a drug dealer
we invited the vampire into the house
just weed was you selling weed he's
selling weed I've been selling a lot of
weed he was selling like pounds yeah of
like chronic chronic is what we called
it in 2000 sure four kind bud in my day
it was kind it was it was KB it was kind
but kind bud it had hairs on it yeah and
uh my roommate was moving weight and
this guy owed the Philly mob a lot of
money for gambling and set up wait this
guy in Arizona oh like is he owed like
the affiliate the story was that this
guy owed the Philly mob like your
roommate did no oh the guy who robbed
him yeah this guy that set it all up
this guy owed the Philly mob like a
hundred thousand dollars in gambling
debt and he was like a rich kid from
California and uh Philly mob was like
well we're gonna kill you and he's like
no you won't yeah like you can't kill me
my dad's rich or whatever he's like look
at your parents and then yeah we don't
give a [__] he was like what and they're
like yeah so you got to give us the
money and so he set up
all the drug dealers he knew and what he
knew my roommate because my roommate had
bought weed off him before and then he
wanted to buy a couple pounds it was a
setup I did the whole story on Ari's
show which was on Comedy Central so you
could watch it on YouTube damn that's a
real story it's 100 happen but
yeah I I think I've smacked my [__] up
into me [__] up the two guys that
robbed us breaking their [__] arm and
then being like no show mercy and I go
Mercy don't live here so it was supposed
to be a lot of chopping dudes in the
neck or breaking their wrists it was
supposed to be a deal where you your
buddy was going to sell him a bunch of
weeds so he had a bunch of wheat on them
yeah so instead these guys came in and
just stole the weed yeah and they went
for them like they and I was in the
apartment I was the roommate my roommate
got away I was there and they [__]
they were like the roommate moves waste
them they don't know how close you were
wait your buddy bolted yeah Lefty in
there well we were coming down the
stairs if you watched the story on
Comedy Central you hear the whole thing
but I had a gun on me and then like he
was like just walk me to the car and I
wasn't like hard or anything like I was
like
I was very soft I was uh I am but I was
I was like I don't want to I'm not gonna
pull a gun on anyone and my roommate is
from Long Island and he was like yeah if
they got a knife and you show him a gun
what do you think they're gonna [__]
do and I was like that is great yeah and
so I was like okay and I just wanted to
smoke a cigarette and I had a barbecue
lighter and a camel light and uh
guy came around the corner and I just
went like this I was like oh boy and the
my shirt lifted up and he saw the gun
and he took my gun off me and then made
me go back in the house and he hit me
with it and then he put my arms zip tied
my arms behind my back what yeah and
then duct tape my feet together
holy and then just kept putting the gun
on my forehead being like oh where's the
[__] money use some cholo some cholo
from south Tucson [__] got me dude
that's the real deal he's like you're
gonna [__] die white boy he kept
saying that you're gonna [__] die
where's the [__] money and I was like
I don't know it's crazy oh yeah go watch
it go watch the story on YouTube yeah
because I I like everything about that
story it took me a long time to work it
out as a bit because it would like bum
people out I am a little bummed out but
it uh it's 100 true I don't like that
that guy was sad he was a pro he had an
army duffel bag folded and tucked into
his back of his jeans so when he put the
money in the bag he like had me and then
he like when he had me on the ground he
like pulled the zip tie zip tied my arms
like fast that and then once he saw that
I was like Inca like I couldn't do
anything he pulled the Army duffel bag
out and started clearing our DVDs and
PlayStation 2 games and [__] wait so
your boy was gone so you were the one he
was grilling yeah did you know where the
cash was yeah did you give it up no
[__] dancing sitting on the ground
going not my Frasier box set yeah those
are my guys that's my Hulk Hogan he took
he took Chappelle season one in season
two big deal at the time he got uh my
Simpsons box set I was mad about that he
got the thing that sucks is they stole
my car and my car had all my laundry in
it Jesus Christ This Guy's cleaned his
the [__] out yeah for real did he find
the money and my backpack with all my
books for that semester and that was
myself
about seven seven hundred did they end
up finding the kid stash no they they
didn't what's funny is like he he like
flipped the mattresses and looked
everywhere and there was a [__] pound
like our claw our hallway went all the
way down into my roommate's room and
like I looked and I was like there's a
pound right there you like moved to
[__] Tower and there was a pound but
the money was in the crawl space and I
just wasn't gonna tell them I was just
like I don't know I don't know but it
was about 30k up in the crawl space
[__] rock solids I don't know man I
don't know I think my roommate wasn't
even like
cool about that he was a dick he was
like yeah I was like you let him take
the Chappelle DVD he's like honestly I
wanted to watch a Rick James Skype today
but yeah he like damn he fled after we
got robbed and then tried to charge me
for the furniture and I was like suck my
dick dude yeah I had a [__] gun that
was you're 30 000. it wasn't a dollar of
my money
yeah dude oh you talk about a guy you
want the [__] Foxhole yeah dude I
don't turn on you I won't turn on you
man you know that's why when people are
like how could you abandon jail I was
like I'll stay with you I stayed with
you I thought you
left the right way but yeah man that was
like um I always Replay that moment and
be like I want to [__] that dude up
and broke his neck and his friend would
really though you killed my friend and I
can get next
Smack My [__] Up
those Caminos yeah has no idea the dirt
that I am done yeah dude I got robbed
and then they found my car I was so mad
they found my car because you want the
insurance yeah and nothing was in my car
no books
guys walking around in your fresh clean
tees too dude I had a I had a Ralph
Wiggum t-shirt and I kept being on there
look how the world's biggest
nine-year-old so you get your Vengeance
this is Ralph Wiggum hey man would you
get that shirt dude for real
my face is on fire it's like I'll
[__] kill you dude I'll kill you
that's my Ralph welcome t-shirt holy
[__] ladies and gentlemen Dan soda I
love you guys we love you too man
[__] unbelievable anything you want
to folks out there to know .com uh live
dates you know I think we just when is
this coming out couple weeks next week
uh Boulder Theater has been announced
the pre-sale is happening at those
tickets Boulder Theater if you're in
Seattle I will be at the Neptune Theater
um we haven't announced any of the other
theaters but then uh clubs all over the
place danceoder.com I'm on tour a lot
I'm I'm heavy on the road one of the
funniest guys doing it Master at the
craft thanks get those tickets go see
them as you know buddy we love you Kippy
what do you got for him guys we're also
all over the road get tickets to those
shows we're announced in the second leg
pretty soon got the suits working on it
right now uh get those tickets before
they sell out we love yous okay we love
you we'll see you next week peace peace